und wir sind mit dem neuen affen inhaber
jetzt verbundenen guten abend herr von
anhalt hallo
vielleicht können sie uns erst mal guten
abend zuallererst sagen wo das äffchen
denn eigentlich herkommen wie es zu
ihnen gekommen dass er vielen stammt
hier aus und so ist stark auch geboren
würde mich noch wie wunderbar das
äffchen stammt aus dem zoo ist er auch
geboren und in diesem zug kann man affen
adoptieren
und ich habe auch schon weißen löwen
adoptiert weil er hat auch schon mit
meiner tochter gespielt als ein baby war
man muss dann quasi das futter bezahlen
meint ihr trainer
wenn fabian ist ein paar jahren haben
wir falsch gelieferte kapuzineräffchen
haben man kann parieren
dann habe ich jetzt umgetauscht in allen
in ein wäldchen und alle sind glücklich
sie sagen gerade man adoptiert dass man
zeit dann also unter anderem für das
futter das heißt die tiere wohnen nicht
tatsächlich bei ihnen sondern haben ab
und zu mal besuche bei ihnen oder wie
genau muss man sich so eine adoption
vorstellen also das tier kann man sich
bringen lassen mit dem tierpfleger auch
weil über das wochenende und drei vier
tage das tier lebt natürlich nicht in
mein haus sondern jetzt lebt so dass
riesengroßes geregelt hat auch
artgenossen mit dem ich spielen kann
aber wir haben halt das privileg dass
durch die unterstützung die wir leisten
finanzielle und wind so dass wir das
tier immer mal wieder nach hause
bekommen das heißt wir gehen nicht in
der zins oder zug kommt zu uns vielen
dank für diese erklärung noch einmal zu
diesen sehr speziellen
weihnachtsgeschenk danke ihnen und ihrer
alten wir haben wir haben auch noch
lösen und einen weißen tiger großartig
schönen abend noch